we are raised in an event oriented
thinking world we see the world as a
complex succession of events rather than
as a system as a whole event oriented
thinking assumes that each event we
experience has a cause and that changing
the cause will correspondingly change
the event however that's the antithesis
of how the world functions famous
systems thinker Donella Meadows writes
in her book thinking in systems a primer
let's face it the universe is messy it
is non-linear turbulent and chaotic it
is dynamic it spends its time in
transient behavior on its way to
somewhere else not in mathematically
need equilibria itself organizes and
evolves it creates diversity not
uniformity that's what makes the world
interesting that's what makes it
beautiful and that's what makes it work